[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était l'année dernière en plein mois
de janvier un jour presque ordinaire
quand l'hiver il avec l'été ce jour là
je croise mon fils en perd joyeux je me
suis exclamé alors ça va mon fils voilà
comment l'histoire a commencé
[Musique]
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé mais
tout allait bien ça c'est certain
et ce jour là ça m'a heurté
c'était soudain presque incertain
je les ai senti dans son regard mais
je ne devais pas faire le mal ça m'est
arrivé sans crier gare
ça m'a miné jusqu'au matin
au début ça commençait bien
c'est à ce moment que tout a basculé
je suis resté là à t'écouter
le regard droit préachat guéret papa
c'est quoi ce phénomène
je vais t'expliquer ski valais
je trouve normal comme une semaine
quatre fois d'affilée je suis contrôlé
je passais juste dans la rue pas par
faut quand même pas exagérer c'est pas
juste ça se fait pas ni moins pourquoi
ils ont amalgamé ça veut dire quoi cette
société où on ne peut même pas se
balader et puis dix mois il est où le
respect quand on juge sur comment tu es
habillée
ça veut dire quoi être citoyen ne pas
l'ouvrir et se la fermer elle est pour
qui la liberté l'égalité la fraternité
je les écoutais sans trop y croire je
les observais sans m'énerver
son regard était vraiment noir snr prêt
à exploser
dans mon esprit wollemi parole
mais sur mes lèvres pas un mot j'ai
tenté de faire le guignol
mais c'est l'humour qui m'a fait défaut
alors j'ai tissé la toile telle une
araignée pour embellir sa réalité
je me suis rangé de son côté sans
dénigrer les gardiens de la paix qui
devant le déferlement des grèves
les manifestations musclées ont pu
abandonner leurs rêves
celui d'être un gardien de la paix je
les guide des deux filles en 28
et pour l'apaiser j'ai désamorcer sous
lance torpilles
laly tempête a été levé alors ça y est
tout est réglé y'a rien à voir circuler
eh bien non pour moi ça n'était pas
terminée j'avais calmer sa colère en
modérant mes propos et mon constat reste
amer me faisant l'effet d'un placebo
était ce un simple dérapage dont je
n'avais pas mesuré la proportion était
ce une simple illusion une simple
émotion de je n'avais que j'avais vécu
avec disproportion je l'avais apaisé
j'avais toutes les raisons d'être
satisfait mais en mon for intérieur
quelque chose me questionner une semaine
s'est écoulée sans que je puisse trouver
la tranquillité
arrive alors cette soirée éclairé par un
simple feu de cheminée dans l'intimité
d'un jeu où l'on exprime ses souhaits
tout c'est le coeur vaillant que je fais
j'aime ces quelques mots
[Musique]
j'aimerais peux m'empêcher
de penser ardemment dans un milieu
privilégié
mon fils était étudiant différent de ses
pairs mais régulièrement pointé tout
cela à cause d'un air
qui flaire trop la cité et que dire de
son frère avec ses yeux azur mais
c'était rien à faire
lui il fait bonne figure
[Musique]
quelle est cette injustice quel est ce
monde un pur ou sans aucun indice
on contrôle al'allure et elle brise de
mer qui souffle sur un brasier
j'ai pensé à mon père qu'il avait
traversé
[Musique]
malgré ses frères d'armes ces médailles
mérité
pour lui je verse une larme pour son
petit fils qu'on amalgame à qui
d'ailleurs est il qu'en est il pour les
autres ce qu'ils ne tiennent qu'à un fil
ceux qui subissent pour d'autres je
pense à ma jeunesse
ou parfois dans le métro avec des
cheveux trop longs
qui tombe sur un perfecto un regard de
travers un style pour 1 comme il le faut
il n'en fallait pas plus
pour être son mais aussi tôt j'hésite
dans mon esprit règne la confusion
réagir tout l'airé jusqu'où ces normes à
respecter les règles juste trop loin
mais jusqu'où qui a tort qui a raison
possible impossible stop en esprit
divague et mon coeur balance
je suis touché au plus profond
je ressens cette chaleur ça n'est plus
un brasier
réfléchir m'appelle et je me mets à sa
place à 17 ans avec les mêmes idéaux que
j'ai pu avoir 35 ans plus tôt j'inspire
n hesitez ce transfert
mon sang ne fait qu'un tour je choisi de
publier sur les réseaux sociaux pour
parler à mon fils c'est parfait attendre
et par les commentaires je sens mon
coeur libérer un mécanisme s'est
enclenché un verrou s'est levé du
deux-roues agents voient se mettent à
max yonnais et c'est au quotidien que je
me surprends à observer ressentir vivre
profondément je saisis ces instants je
regarde au présent apaisé par la lune
inspiré par le vent
[Musique]
non
mais
[Musique]
j'aurais pu lui mentir sans vraiment
bien y croire
juste pour tenter de faire et je n'en
menais pas large
c'est vraiment sale histoire il faut
savoir le dire une émotion de trous une
aubaine comme il faut qui m'a juste fait
bouger une énergie motrice une voix
réparatrice pour mes paroles cash de
quoi j'me mêle d'encouragement mais
pourquoi je m'interpelle
c'est quoi ce bordel est bien réelle
c'est sûrement l'essentiel
crier ne sert à rien déclaré c'est plus
sage moi ça me plaît davantage cela mais
ça me fait du bien c'est une histoire de
langage
un message quand j'ai le vague à l'âme
jeudi l'aïe
dans un océan de flammes
quand j'en fais pas c'est ça le slam de
là quand l'émotion ne gagne seymour
essai qui trompe le monopole dans le
tumulte de mes paroles surgit parfois le
pas ras bol moi qui pensais être urbain
tout en partant sans lendemain
moi qui rêvais d'être humain sans
chronomètre au quotidien je cherche ma
voix et paroles s'envolent
je m'exclame sans état d'âme je pose mes
mots j cole des notes
j'imprime
bon phonogrammes et si je suis papou est
même pas chanteur encore moins musicien
je m'exclame avec tout mon coeur c'est
ça qui compte
j'y tiens
la gamme je divague dans un océan de
flammes
j'avance d'alinghi da sans faire de vaca
ccao le slam au delà
[Musique]
fait des zigzags telle une sinusoïde
avec des hauts et des bas pour ne pas
vivre comme un android mais ressentir
mon coeur qui bat et quand mon iphone
devient à fun je veux synchro mais à
mouna qui me fait vibrer comme une belle
personne sans électrocardiogramme
l'audace et mâcon pas
la cocaïne
c'est celle qui dit impôt
c'est elle qui en prime c'est elle qui
me lis
plus haut
c'est vrai que j'ai pas parlé comme
d'habitude j'ai dû abuser c'est
mais c'est une certitude c'est mon coeur
qui me l'a soufflé tout
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]